now Ecuador's government has just agreed
to repeal a law that ended decades-old
fuel subsidies after holding talks with
indigenous leaders earlier demonstrators
angry at the rise in fuel prices
attached government buildings and burnt
media offices they were defying a
government imposed curfew in the capital
Quito protests first began nearly two
weeks ago
but mani rapado joins us live now from
Quito man also just bring us up to date
on what's been agreed between both sides
well there are celebrations taking place
on the streets of quito right now if you
can hear behind me there's fireworks
going on cars honking their own horns
people celebrating what's what's been
deemed an agreement finally between a
confederation of indigenous communities
from across the country that have been
protesting for over a week calling on
the government to reverse course on a
economic policy that that sought to and
decades were decades long fuel subsidies
an austerity program that the government
that many saw is being damaging for the
country and they seem to have managed to
come up with an agreement with the
government where that's exactly what
they're going to get the government has
decided to abandon this policy measure
and instead form a commission and
inclusive commission that takes into
account the voices and participation of
indigenous leaders to find not only a
solution out of this crisis but an
economic policy that's beneficial to all
sectors of society so this is something
that that we personally were not
expecting to be reporting this evening
given what we saw take place earlier
today a continuation of clashes between
demonstrators and protesters people in
the streets saying that they've lost
confidence and the government lost
confidence in the president calling on
the resignation of president president
letting Modi know so this is certainly
good news and hopefully it means a
lasting peace for the streets of Quito
and and the rest of the country yeah and
it's just about to ask you about it so
where does this then leave the curfew
and the other restrictions pace against
the protesters well on Saturday that
curfew was announced nationwide on
Sunday morning that curfew was lifted
partially for the country except for one
sector of Quito specifically the areas
where many of the demonstrators
we're staying we're sleeping now we
should mention however that despite this
curfew a lot of people were still
defying the curfew a lot of
demonstrators are still taking to the
streets still clashing with police into
the night that appears to be over but we
should mention that indigenous leaders
have condemned the heavy crackdown the
repression against peaceful protesters
by authorities here in Quito they cited
a few statistics here more than 2,000
people have been wounded since these
these clashes broke out more than a week
ago ten people have killed and have been
killed unfortunately since the start of
the unrest here in the country's capital
and more than a thousand people have
been arrested so there's still there's
still many things that need to be ironed
out there still calls for justice for
the people that have been killed there's
still calls for an investigation into
those who have been wounded including
members of the press so while while
there is a lot of optimism and a lot of
hope that this could mean a lasting
peace there are still many things that
need to be ironed out before before
people can can can safely say that that
calm and peace has returned to the
streets of Quito
alright Imani rappeller there in the
Ecuadorian capital Manuel thank you